man it's almost heartbreaking this is
going to go onto a deck instead in the
wall on the walls in the house or
something it's just gorgeous
wood this Western red cedar is expensive
but it's light and it's really rot
resistant so it won't be no more
slashing and splashing when the girls
are running around in circles out
here hey
Timber
yeah I'll have you be inside today I'm
going to have to pull this whole all
this all these bases they're all rotten
hey we we don't want anyone to go glun
no we don't need to be swimming today
it's kind of cold
yeah now it's just destroy time
time oh jeez thing is so
rotten it's very labor intensive out
here to get anything out here is labor
intensive it just takes uh three times
as long to get anything
done but all we got's time I ain't dying
today it's all got to come up
everything's rotten and
heavy every board I pull off I learn
more and more about how this thing was
put together and and how to fix it I'm
tearing up a part of history but I want
to fix it better than it was Camp 36 is
kind of a museum on water and I want to
keep it as close to the history as I
can the sea life that's under here is
just amazing it's crazy I got sea stars
and muscles and all sorts of things
under here we're just a floating
Reef getting close to halfway done with
this tear down
but the only tricky part
is watching my step and not going in
between the logs
here I'd like to get the framing down
and just get some boards throwed down up
here so we can we can still get
[Music]
around that one's rotten might just be
safer to walk the logs now this this is
eyeball carpentry all day long it's uh I
don't think there's a level spot on this
house but it's just what it is I mean
even a house on land you got to replace
decking it's just the challenge of it
out here is you fall in the water if you
fall off the deck you know contemplating
my life decisions right at this
moment
dang I knew this one was going to be
tough since my wife fleshed I'm out here
alone come off there that's the
challenging part of this now it's hard
to not have that help you know I got the
girls and they help when they can but
them little girls aren't going to pack a
a 4x8 post or
beam I've got to do all the back
breaking
work but it's also gratifying to know I
don't need anybody I don't I don't have
to have
anybody I mean I put the beams down put
my cross braces
on look at
that that
worked
[Music]